hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd youtube video and in this one i'm
going to try to show you guys the new
dimensions of the youtube widescreen
player the really wide screen player
now if you go to your youtube channel
such as mine where i uploaded my most
recent tutorial in the full youtube
widescreen i don't know if you guys have
seen this one yet but it does take up
the entire screen so if you look at this
as i'm talking in this video here with
my eyes closed i have uh the entire
youtube widescreen filled up and this i
actually kind of like it the way it
lines up with the rest of the youtube
page with the right and left edges
unfortunately it's not the usual 720p or
1080p that you guys are used to so the
dimensions of the new youtube widescreen
player are
1920x960 not
by 1920x1080 but 1920 by 960. i'll put
that in the description just so you guys
can remember this and favorite it if you
need help remembering but that is the
dimension to the you the new youtube
mega widescreen player and i actually
kinda like it now if you're viewing this
video in the smaller condensed size
there will be little very small black
bars on the top and the bottom because
this is a little bit thinner than 16 by
nine and obviously thinner than 16 by 10
but i just felt like getting this video
up to you guys uh to let you guys know
i'm actually a little bit sick right now
so i pardon my voice but i just felt
like you know letting you guys know for
all of you who have asked just to put it
out there is 1920 by 960 officially so
thank you for watching this youtube
video i hope this was helpful and i'll
be actually uploading an mkbhd update
video very soon so i'll stay tuned for
that again thanks for your support so
far and i'll be answering as many
questions as i can on this account
because obviously this is one i'm
connected to most people with so again
thank you for watching and i'll talk to
you guys in the next video peace